so midterms
midterms why your interest in UK why
such interest in the midterms of U.S
because you are our hope as well you are
the light shining on the top of the hill
you are Our Hope in the UK we're already
lost we're already gone demographically
alone if you just disregard me if you
loathe me hate everything I am that's
fine but by 2030 Muslim births outnumber
births to all other in my country we're
gone every city wait what did you just
are you serious
did you hear what she just said the fact
you can have a Google hold this up
but Muslim person UK out at number any
and all other religion by 2030. wow oh
by 20 oh my God
wow wow
so they're not using condoms that's
basically Having Eight Kids each what
okay Muslim numbers to double by Twenty
every every British City uh that mayor
in every British City I mean the big
cities is Muslim why is that though why
is that you see the same model here
Minneapolis versus Minnesota Minneapolis
highly prevalent Muslim population
densely organized into Collective
housing situations when they vote you'll
only ever get Muslim leadership there we
will never have a non-muslim mayor of
London again it's statistically
impossible
you will never have a non-muslim mayor
ever again yeah of London London will
always go to a Muslim
because the population of London is now
densely packed Muslim population was
that strategic or did that accidentally
no no there's nothing accidental this is
strategic Power Player taking over of a
Nation so back to topic hence the US is
our hope as well in the sense that this
is where Freedom will live and this is
why I care about the midterms and that's
why I'm on the road
and your messaging on the road is what
what do you what are you hitting on on
the road the ice is decided by ours I
mean the side that simply wants the best
for each other right so ours is the side
that wants everyone to be all right and
ours is the side that's been through a
lot locked down wiped out businesses
wiped out families split people up got
people Uninvited from weddings and that
their synagogue and it destroyed
people's lives and people felt utterly
lost and then you had the installation
of Biden which I was there for in DC and
people have been wondering what on Earth
is happening to America people sit in
comfortable Studios like this but I've
just come up from downtown Atlanta and
white people are basically being hunted
and targeted in the streets it happened
in front of me I've seen white people
when they start to Scurry in downtown
places they Scurry like rats happened in
Minneapolis happens in downtown Atlanta
and that's the truth of these cities in
America and we can't let that happen
here it's already happened in my country
we can't have it happen here so so for
people in America who are maybe this
isn't in their top 10 concerns when they
wake up in the morning of course it's
not and they're just sitting there
saying well that's your problem that's
happening in the UK it'll never happen
to us so two questions I would want you
to address one who cares about this
issue why should we be afraid if they do
do this because some people are not
concerned about that and then the second
thing is what are like the likelihood of
that happen in the states
um number one no I totally understand
most people have to try and get up
they've got to try and get their kids
out the door they've got to find someone
to help them find their car keys they've
got to try and get to work they can't
afford this that or the other and then
probably the dog ran off down the road
and started humping the neighbor's leg
like that's the reality of our everyday
it's a real issue it's a real issue I
I'm I am a regular mother I I do have
it's surprising I know but I like I have
a husband I I have three teenage
children like I have I have two dogs I
get the thing that's more important
but uh the reason it matters is because
people need hope and they need to
believe in something and people out
there
are battered right now people come up to
me in tears when I do talks and we have
time together and they're in a room with
people who just want them to be all
right people are in tears because they
are exhausted by being surrounded by
endless madness here in America and I
find that really hard people want to
believe in democracy they want to
believe in freedoms they want to believe
in things like medicine and for the last
couple of years many people feel those
things are falling apart
um but my message isn't a negative one
it is a really optimistic one I love our
side I love uh Americans because you
have freedom hardwired into your souls
and you have a second amendment that I
that I applaud and uh you know it's part
of that message is to that we keep going
our fight will always be uphill so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]